[Music]
[Applause]
I'm Mathison today February of 2017
marks a 1-dimensional occasion in
American history where as we've seen
every single woman in the country has
gone on strike in a sign of solidarity
all living across the United States have
refused to work to serve or be in any
measurable use to the rest of the
country we have Jimmy our on-the-ground
reporter in Los Angeles what are you
seeing there on the ground Jimmy yes
Barry thank you initially most
remarkable to see is the fact that there
is no traffic whatsoever to be found
there no no one is there no traffic you
mean because of fewer people on the road
with women on strike no Perry I mean no
traffic whatsoever for the first time
cars are using the left lane exclusively
for its intended purpose of passing turn
signals are being used properly and the
incidence of text and driving accidents
are now non occurrences remarkable is
there anything else alone on the ground
remarkably employers across Los Angeles
are claiming that productivity has
increased by over 42% HR infractions
have fallen to a number to negligible to
even register and the Dow Jones is at a
record high of 25,000 also self-reported
levels of experienced fun have nearly
double Mary no flash a living woman with
human lives for it now Perry I must
caution these results are not without
negative ramifications to all men on the
ground it is my journalistic duty to
inform you and issue a warning that we
have seen an alarming number of a week
slightly dry hey if you like this video
subscribe by clicking the button that
says subscribe if you're not aware of it
now there's no way you're learning the
Internet at this point I'm not going to
help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit.com slash mug club
members of your student military or
veteran entering that promo code it's
less than $6 a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand
etched mug oh I just when I feel it I
got a chill like on the inside